[Music]
can I help you
st. Peter yeah what can I get in yeah I
don't think so it's a sausage party in
there well Jimmy Dean Fiesta bro
it's about ratio let's put it this way
last time I saw Jesus around by 12 dudes
it was 2000 years ago on earth now you
can't find him amidst all the glorious
tush I probably on your list there Oh oh
you think you should be on the list hold
on Gabriel can I run someone by you real
fast yeah it's a it's a man from pee let
himself go looks like he makes his own
clothing
yeah he's pale he's very pale smells
like dip um I think it's like a vinegar
dip like a vinegar base damn maybe like
a little bit of cream in there but
mostly a vinegar dip any dip it's a no I
tried I really tried
you know actually no a couple of people
that are already in there oh oh oh I'm
sorry you know someone you know someone
who died great let me put you at the
bottom of this special list I have
called everyone you know what actually I
was in there and I just left real quick
to smoke a cigarette smoking take a look
around there's no cigarettes here just
ambrosia and Molly unless you have weed
we're running low on weed are you hold
are you holding no probably your one
chance to get in blew it but if I led a
good life shouldn't I get into heaven
yeah that's the thing we're not heaven
anymore it's totally overhauled its hvm
whoo there's no correct way to pronounce
it actually two new afterlife experience
by Jean Vaughn do any clips
there's no harps or robes it's just
designer suits and bottle service a
sequined samurai on the back of a
tasteful night jacket it's fierce it's
dope and fierce its fiercely dope sounds
like hell
actually no house just where we keep all
the dudes
smells like body spray oh this is my jam
this is my jam oh it's dope and fierce
and tight and real
[Music]